I say that man is entitled to his own  happiness and that he must achieve it  himself she was a capitalist which  annoyed people on the left and she was  an atheist which annoyed people on the  right I read and within two sentences I  felt hypnotized the joy of watching that  mind at work was something I've never  experienced before or since in an ever  expect to Iran has the best job of  making the moral case for democratic  capitalism more than anybody else join  reason TV as we celebrate the enduring  power of ein Rand's ideas featuring  exclusive interviews with Nathaniel  Branden Barbara Brandon and the founding  editors of Reason magazine  you